see this guy he is afraid for his life
this drawing is in 1832 joke it's a riff
on how nobody knew how to prevent
cholera
you might suspend a chorus over your
masked mouth or wear a copper
breastplate and tie pictures of water
behind your calves anything to keep the
disease away
[Music]
starting in 1830s cholera pandemics
swept the United Kingdom nobody knew how
the disease was transmitted germs
weren't an established idea one London
doctor Jon Snow tried to find out how
the disease spread and today one of his
investigations is iconic in the field of
Epidemiology
and it all centered on a pump this is a
map John snow made to prove his solution
to the cholera mystery in London it also
shows the confusion and the problems he
was up against each of these bars
represents a death from cholera the
disease often killed half the people who
got it
it caused vomiting and diarrhea the
rapid loss of fluids was fatal at the
time a lot of people believed cholera
was transmitted in a miasma imagine in
evil cholera cloud this typical map from
the 1840s shows a cholera mist that was
blamed for transmission snow suspected a
different source
[Music]
at the time people usually didn't get
water directly in their homes it came
from a neighborhood pump connected to
one of the few water companies in the
city John snow mapped different water
companies service areas in London you
can see how they are occasionally
separate and occasionally overlap if a
common pump was contaminated at any
point at the source or near the pump
snow believed the water could kill in
18-49 he wrote that his study of
symptoms and specific cases had led him
to suspect the emptying of sewers into
the drinking water of the community
caused outbreaks not a miasma five years
later he had a chance to prove it and
stop a fresh outbreak in the process in
August 1854 20 people lived here at
forty Broad Street including an infant
who died of cholera after her death snow
started to investigate the outbreak he
didn't think the original water source
was the problem but he thought something
might be wrong down the line at the pump
he took samples of the water they seemed
clean but he wasn't satisfied because
more people were getting sick he asked
questions up and down the street where
one man had noticed a bad smell from his
water snow ask the Registrar for a list
of people who died he started going
house by house to interview the
survivors and many of the dead had taken
water from the pump he became convinced
the Broad Street pump was the common
link among the dead he wrote I had an
interview with the board of guardians of
st. James Parish on the evening of
Thursday 7th September and represented
the above circumstances to them in
consequence of what I said the handle of
the pump was removed on the following
day people stopped using the water but
snow had not won yet newspapers reported
the streets were covered in line the
city was using it as a powerful
disinfectant on the streets that showed
they weren't fully convinced the pump
was the problem they
suspected miasma so snow bolstered his
case through investigation and recording
he learned the 18 workers who died at
this factory had drunk from big barrels
of water drawn from the pump at the same
time unlikely survivors could serve as
proof of snows theory according to
miasma theory this place would have been
covered in cholera clouds affecting all
workers but snow learned the workhouse
had its own well know bad water got in
the same went for this Brewer
that's because snow learned the workers
their drink from the breweries water
supply or more likely only drank a free
malt liquor they got on the job that's
right drinking on the job saved their
lives
snow strengthened his argument and his
map he adjusted the location of the pump
to show how close it was to 40 Broad
Street and drew a dotted line he showed
a zone where it would be closest to walk
to the Broad Street pump rather than
another one that zone is where most
people died he tabulated every death by
date to do it this was paired with a
local reverence similar data-driven
investigations a local surveyor looked
at the plumbing at 40 Broad Street where
the infant had died he learned that the
cesspool were sewage collected was
poorly designed and lined with decaying
bricks when the infants diapers had been
washed the cholera carrying water had
leaked into the Broad Street pump supply
Jon Snow died in 1858 his obituary read
dr. Jon Snow this well-known physician
died at noon on the 16th instant at his
house in Sackville Street from an attack
of apoplexy his researches on chloroform
and other anesthetics were appreciated
by the profession at the time
snow was more famous for stuff like a
chloroform inhaler than a map it took
years for the investigation of Jon Snow
to become an example for subsequent
outbreaks and epidemiology textbooks and
it's slowly eventually helped end the
miasma myth that's because snow did not
just make a map of a city it's a map of
his process in the field it shaped it
gave direction to a world where disease
didn't have to be hidden in a cloud
instead it could start at a pump
[Music]
okay so the best book about John Snow is
cholera chloroform in the science of
medicine features an amazing story which
is that Jon Snow gave chloroform to
Queen Victoria while she was giving
birth